winners are people who first love to win
and don't see losing as opportunity so
they they understand that they may lose
in you know one one bottle but they need
to to win the war or win the the whole
game you know welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of fam Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with eldad postan Quran 37 and
the founder of the CEO of win AI a
startup that builds an artificial
intelligence-based personal assistant
for salespeople the company has been
operating for less than a year raised 17
million dollars as an initial investment
and has 25 employees the idea behind
when AI came after leading sales at
Dreama diabetes where he started as a
Salesman himself in the past he also
worked at the Venture Capital fund our
crowd as responsible for the business
development of the portfolio companies
in addition eldad has been an active
entrepreneur for the past decade in
recent years he and his heart surgeon
wife Ronnie co-founded chavot a
non-profit organization for Girls
Leadership the organization is already
active in 26 cities with over 3 000
female volunteers shavot is also the
leader of Israeli girls week where more
than 100 000 girls and teenagers will
partake in activities meant to inspire
women this year in the past founded the
sky's the limit Association that
promoted social entrepreneurship for
at-risk Youth and served as chairman of
the Student Union at the Hebrew
University he also served as an officer
in the Israeli Navy
we're gonna have a really good time over
these 20 minutes talking about your
journey and not just for the Journey of
win Ai and talking about sales people
are and the intersection of artificial
intelligence but also looking a little
bit on your journey a little bit broader
broader than that with shavot and the
different organizations you've been a
part of you've been in so many different
Industries in so many different types of
roles that I can already sense from your
energy you know the type of person that
would go exactly well let's start Daryl
dot you know connect the dots for me on
your journey who is eldad there are so
many different things you were doing
um
it's a good question I think that the
the major character that I can say that
goes along in my whole career is taking
responsibility and I know it's like
sound a little bit cliche but uh I think
that this is the main you know my my
main motivation is to take
responsibility whether it's about my
community
um you know about the university when I
was in the University uh and then that
goes along so I'm I'm I'm this guy that
you know takes responsibility even
though it's it's you know it's very
yellow to say
um but it is that that's the truth
well um when you're what do you mean by
that because there's all sorts of ways
in it taking responsibility you're
taking it much more from an
entrepreneurial perspective how does
that come up how does that come to place
so I think that the way that I take
responsibility is when I see something
that is is wrong or broken or that I can
feel that I can do better
I I will step you know step up and and
do something about it I won't you know
way that someone else will do it for me
or someone else will improve the
situation
um so I'm taking responsibility by
definition
I I love that definition give me an
example let's look at chavot for example
what what was that taking what was that
about taking responsibility yeah so like
five years ago 2018
um Roni my wife she's a fast surgeon
um today back then she was in med school
um and so we felt that we want to do
something together it was just after we
both left the the Student Union of the
Hebrew University and I I was after
shifting to startups and and you know
the high-tech world and I felt that
something is missing like the ebook is
missing and she left the Student Union
so we we thought okay let's see if we
can do something together and together
we we started a very interesting
conversation which actually was part of
a hitchhike hitchhiking that we did
together
and we asked ourselves like what yes the
one thing that you want to change in the
world what is the one thing that uh um
you find it you know that peace you
um and then we thought about
lack of editing
I don't know if I don't want to call it
the gender gap or the the differences
between men and women the chances and
opportunities uh between men and women
in our current world so we thought about
how we can you know as a couple and as a
team how we can change the world in this
aspect and we thought about a program
for girls and to teach young girls how
to be leaders in their Community whether
it's about how to
um set goals and to debrief themselves
and then we started to read lots of
research researchers from Stanford
University and this is how you know this
is was the the team moment where shavod
was born it was a hitchhiking of four
days from the Mediterranean to the
gandalasi and we we spoke about that and
this is how we started to we started
with 10 girls in Jerusalem uh five years
ago today we have more than three
thousand years uh from you know from
North of Israel to the south of Israel
that on a weekly basis going through a
leadership program as we teach them not
to eat you know personally today but we
have more than 200 instructors
they teach them how to be leaders in
their community so this was one example
and
if you're looking let's just look a
little bit more broadly speaking and
then we'll dive into win AI if you're
looking at this concept of taking
ownership and taking responsibility over
something that you care about or that
you see is wrong or not working the way
that you think it should obviously it's
there's a lot of friction in taking
responsibility and taking ownership
let's break the myth how do we break the
myth how do we get somebody who truly
does care about something to take action
and take responsibility really kind of
in the way that you did with the with
shavot
so I think that my the the the the way
it works words for me at least is baby
steps
it's not like Shabbat or with AI was
built
one day out of nowhere you know out of
out of Justin you know I'm sitting in
the room and puff the day after me it
happens I really believe in in small
successes you know let's start with you
know just recruiting the four students
let's just you know make success by
recruiting 10 girls
you know one step after another and I
think that the fact that I'm able to
move very fast in the long term but have
the patience for the long term it's like
it's a good combination because this is
how I I managed to to achieve small
small successes but over time it makes a
big difference so I think that it's it's
just a matter of motivation dedication
and hard working
we're stacking into consideration that
you're gonna fail and I fail like
thoughts
it is sort of but uh you have to fail um
you have to fail in it well sometimes
someone ever so have to like fail
fabulously like you can't just fail if
you fail you have to you know have an
extravagant failure that actually means
something a lot of people sort of like
have a mellow fail but I love to I like
to have extravagant fail so that I can
really Crush from it but it's just a
personal touch yeah exactly let's talk
about the artificial intelligence and
sales what's happening there I mean I
love AI
I am okay with sales I need to get
better at it but how do we how do these
two worlds Come Together by the way this
is the number one profession which is
not to learn in school should be taught
in school is how to sell but anyway
um so I think that AI so let's start
there
yeah because let's talk about being
being a good salesperson is not only
about
um you know selling a product or selling
a service it's about the ability to have
you know the ability to to to to to have
a message and that the other side will
receive the message and to understand
that communication is not only about the
words is also about the emotion and and
ability to to you know to do public
speaking I think that in the uh you know
in the US is more on Advanced when you
have um show and tell in the
kindergarten in Israel that's that's
nobody tells you how to be a public
speaker from day one and I think that
being a salesperson is is amazing uh
toolkit for people whatever you want to
do because hiring people is doing sales
you know getting customers is doing
sales fundraising is doing sales this is
all the same things all the same
methodologies same mindset
um but that's that's about sales
um how do AI get get Institute into the
uh
to the picture so I think that let's
take a step back if if I may and I think
that AI it once again it's a tool and I
think that the problem is in cells and
that that's a very very common problem
with 90 90 of the salespeople don't Club
to track and build labs to update the
CRM after each and every call because
it's tedious and it's boring and it's
like tons of manual work
the industry speaks about between 20 to
of the time of a salesperson updating
the CRM this is ridiculous it's like
tons of time and
and I think that a i as a tool and you
know you can use the AI for you know
endless
scenarios I think that there's a really
really strong use case for solving these
very common problem like this is one
once again every salesperson will tell
you that
um and this is actually the one problem
we are trying to solve in win AI like to
take the word of notes taking uh
Playbook tracking any and updating to
the CRM using Ai and the other side of
the same coin is how to help sales
leaders VP cell cro directors and so on
to help them to increase the adoption of
the Playbook which is usually you know
sits on the shelf and nobody uses it
um so this is that that's a true uh
scenario and a true uh opportunity here
to use the AI to solve true problems
yeah if we're looking at a division for
when AI let's let's play it you know a
few years down the line what is the role
that AI is playing in in sales or
conversations or or changing the
landscape of the way companies are
closing things
so I think that it's you know we don't
need to wait for Mark Zuckerberg for uh
metabirth
I think that today we're leaving you
know what now even you know you and me
we are communicating through a digital
channel and and why not why why
shouldn't be here you know use augmented
reality based on that digital channel
now
I don't know out communicating with
candidates customer prospects service
providers like tons of people that I
communicate through with you know video
conference to zoom whatever it is
and I think it just makes sense and this
is not a trend this is you know this is
how life's modern look like in the
global world and I think it just makes
sense to utilize the fact that we are
communicating on a digital channel to
have augmentation of knowledge and
augmentation that captured the knowledge
and augmentation that helps my life to
be better and and to to be to make me
super productive and I think that this
is the vision of when I within is not
about cells win AI is about helping
people to remove the manual tasks in
their day-to-day it could be in sales it
could be in customer success it could be
in support it could be in sales
development it could be but also in
telemedicine and and HR interviews each
one of us who communicate on video
conferences it just makes sense to have
this kind of augmentation that helps you
to be superhuman
I have to say that
you know and I encourage anybody
listening here to just go to when AI
website because it's a it's it's one of
the most fun websites that I've been to
and I usually don't recommend people to
do things as they're listening to this
uh but it really is anymore go and come
back but the reason why I'm saying it is
because I'm listening to you talk and
I'm listening to you talk about you know
this problem and your personality and it
just I can see why the website is the
way that it is I would be very surprised
if you didn't have a major impact in in
the way that it is I'm gonna be very
transparent I feel that it's a little
bit too much
but then I was convinced by Ariana
Grande and he's like our director of
growth that this is what we should do
and I said let's do it and I today I
love it I'm so proud
it looks like you're living it it's
pretty it's pretty awesome tell me a
little bit about the personas that are
you know into win AI I was trying to get
I was trying to look through you know
the offering in the website I mean
obviously first of all you know the the
problem space is very clear the types of
people that need to use it I mean I can
clearly see you know the huge benefits
of this and honestly if I I I want to
use one AI for for this podcast itself
just because I I it just makes perfect
sense but tell me a little bit about
sort of the personas within the
organizations that are sort of consider
as the early adopters or the people that
are really buying into this
so I think that today I can split the
audience into three uh you have the um
self-development people uh once again
today we do not support dieters but we
do support video conferences and some of
the videos ideas or the xdrs so call
them today uh use zoom for qualification
and you know the top of the final
conversation
um so this is one uh uh uh Persona the
second Persona is the AE
um the county executive the salesperson
usually in in a software company uh but
I think that the third person who use a
winner today is they he who doesn't sell
software necessarily because we need to
remember that we have like tons of
people who sell software but we have you
know around 10 times more account
executive who do not sell uh software
and this is you know a huge
uh opportunity that we see and we target
them as well
um so
Sellers from sdrs to
um account executive software and not
software this is the three main uh
Persona and of course we have their
managers that will also benefit from our
value proposition
and as you as you see this the company
growing how what what are the main
Milestones that you foresee for one AI
in the near future as you're growing
this either from a product perspective
from an offerings perspective or
technology
so first I want to support all of the
video conferences I want to support all
of the dialers so the idea is that I
will be able to support sdrs with
database from one end to customer
success and so forth on the other end by
the way when we will be able to do that
we will also solve a very big problem in
organization in management of the data
between in the head-offs between sdr3
account executive account executive to
customer success or sales engineer and
so on so this is also going to be a huge
solution for you huge problem
um and I think that this is one and the
other end is to keep improving the AI
ability of tracking and capturing and
and truly understanding the the con
conversation because just to give you a
quick example when I will ask you
um how many employees are you and your
asset will be 20 or 20 employees or I
would ask you how many many employees
are are you 20 employees sorry and your
answer will be yes these are three ways
to ask the same questions and machine
won't necessarily will understand the
same answer and I think that the
understanding of the context this is
like 90 percent of con of human
conversation is the understanding of the
context there is not the understanding
of the words and this is where we're aim
again we see now like the beginning of
uh uh success in this
effort as well
I love it so obviously eldad you're very
intentional and you care a lot I mean
those I think two things that I can come
out of this conversation with pretty
clear conviction on tell me about why
you founded when AI what was it
um
so first I I from my personal experience
as a salesperson until today I suck it
at filling out this event truly
unfortunately and so first I I built the
product for myself like it will be fun
if other people will use it but I build
it for myself uh that's first but second
I think that
the the the the opportunity to do
something huge scalable
uh Global because Chavo today is amazing
but you know it's all only only in
Israel and I think that the opportunity
to solve a global problem and to affect
life of millions and to improve their
life and to make their life better I
think that's that's my my major
motivation and inspiration in what we do
that's awesome and if you had to think
about the optimal type of person to work
with you on this journey as obviously as
the company grows and and I'm sure that
everybody's talking about culture these
days but but you know if we're looking
at actually the type of person that that
you would want as a part of the sort of
the family that wins together at win AI
you know what is this type of person and
I have a feeling that this is it's an
important question to ask you because of
your intentionality and the fact that
you've worked with so many different
teams and you're you really are
operating from a place of of
transparency and authenticity who is the
type of person that that you want to
partner with on this journey
once again let's do another cliche
winners
uh and and you know winners by heart
because the winners
are people who first love to win and
don't see it look losing as opportunity
so they in you they understand that they
may lose in you know one one bottle but
they need to to win the war or win the
the whole game you know
um so people who are have perseverance
and and people who have uh um be no
longer to to get out of their Comforts
on it to do new things and to work with
other people similar to their mindset I
think that's the the first thing
and I think that
so the second thing is also connected to
the the first one I think that you need
to be team player
you can't win alone this is not you know
this is not a marathon that you are
running alone it's all about the ability
to connect on and communicate
very very transparently very very easily
with other people today we sit in our
office we have a new office in Ramadan
so we sit together there are no walls
between the different teams because
cells need to be able to communicate
with development and development need to
be able to communicate with product
without boundaries and I think that
people with the ability to communicate
well and work well as a team this is you
know that's that's a a requirement it's
not nice to have it this is a
requirement in order to win and I'm
looking for people like that
I love it a very very cool eldadu thank
you so much for your time for your
energy and insights and I can't wait to
continue being a cheerleader from the
side
um join us
well I'm gonna have to to film to to
fail extravagantly with my own startup
first even though definitely not
planning on failing but thank you very
very much eldad and and seriously I urge
anybody to go to your website just
because it's it's it's an experience so
take care of that thank you and good
luck thank you have a great day
thank you